with dexter i'm excited to put something
out there that that answers
some questions that have been floating
around which are essentially what the
hell happened to this guy
hey guys pete here there was a dexter
panel at the summer tca and they did
give away a lot of details and
information about the upcoming revival
special event series or if you prefer
season 9. all in all some really
interesting stuff interviews with the
cast and the creators and accompanied by
some new promo images and a new behind
the scenes teaser reel with lots of new
footage of the season i'm gonna talk
about all of that and some of it is
somewhat spoilerish although it is all
promotional stuff at this point but i
will give you the warning if you wanted
to go into this season cold this video
isn't for you
in my last dexter video i talked about
jennifer carpenter's return reprising
her role as deb and the popular guess
was that she would take over for harry
as the person inside dex's head who he
works his stuff out with this has now
been confirmed and they revealed that
she'll be there right from the beginning
this is something that he's already
worked out and it's a part of his
personality at this point you see a
couple of new shots of them together and
what's funny is that clyde phillips said
that they were planning on keeping this
as a big secret until john lithgow gave
it away
so just to be clear dexter was never
seeing a vision or harry's ghost or
something like that it was always
something that he created in his head
where he could draw on what harry had
taught him and try to make the right
decisions
in season eight he moved past this he
said goodbye to harry he didn't need him
anymore and now we know that deb will
take his place so she's not just there
for flashbacks or her cameo but she'll
be a cast regular for the season the
showrunner said i think deb represents a
corner of dexter's mind that we all have
in our own heads that says well wait a
minute if you do this then here are the
consequences and then you decide whether
or not to do it whether or not to pursue
it jennifer carpenter added that she
sees herself playing an echo or an
inconvenient truth for dexter and said
that she was really excited to come back
and to take on the character this way
clyde phillips also confirmed that more
original cast members are coming back
beyond just deb and trinity which so far
they have been able to keep secret i
suppose this means we might see angel
quinn masuka henna elway jamie astor or
cody i mean that's about it as far as
living people and then of course there
are a lot of dead ones that could show
up in his mind and i left harrison out
of this list on purpose because that was
the other big thing they confirmed
showtime posted this photo on their
twitter account of jack alcott and
michael c hall on set together with the
caption harrison is that you it had been
speculated that alcott was going to be
playing dexter's son and during the
panel they made this plane not only
would harrison show up in the very first
episode but that they wanted to make
this one of the themes of the season the
father and son relationship it appears
that they're aging up harrison a little
bit he would have been 12 to 14 i think
based on the timeline so i imagine that
he's a little bit older than that
considering they're saying that he
tracked dexter down in the interview
they said his son always thought he was
dead and then found out he was alive and
has a great resentment
so part of dex's story in the season is
that he has a lot of work to do to win
his son back and prove that he could be
a good father and i guess that we'll
just have to see how that plays out
because we have no idea how this is
going to come together the last we saw
of harrison he was a young child he had
been taken to argentina by hannah so
there's a lot of story to fill in as far
as how he found out that dexter faked
his own death how a teenager can just
travel wherever he wants track down
someone that doesn't want to be found
there's a lot of questions there and
there's also a lot of questions about
what dexter's been up to but apparently
they're not going to spend much time
dwelling on that michael c hall said
that he's basically been nomadic saying
again that at least in this period of
time he's trying not to kill but
obviously he's gonna be doing some
killing because of what we've seen in
the trailers in the latest behind the
scenes video we can see him making a
blood slide we see him standing at the
incinerator there's definitely somebody
inside and deb's there with him and one
of the things they said that jumped out
to me right away was that the entire
thing happens in a period of about 2
weeks so you have 10 episodes showing
about 14 days which could mean that
there'll be a pretty hectic pace with
all this stuff happening so quickly they
stress that they wanted this to be
something entirely new that this wasn't
just the ninth season of dexter not only
did they move away from miami but they
also wanted to change things up in the
way that the season was structured where
in the past they had the kills of the
week and the one person he pursued
throughout the whole thing the big bad
this time we might see something
different
and you're probably wondering about the
ending is it a setup so they can make
more seasons the showtime execs said
that they can't call it a limited series
because it's already had a bunch of
seasons but that they see it as a
limited event series they had an idea
for 10 episodes they wanted to put
everything into making those the best
that they could and therefore they
weren't answering any questions about
whether there might be more
they're saying things that make it sound
like it's gonna have a definitive ending
things like it's a proper finale for a
brilliant series and they also seem to
be taking some responsibility for how it
ended the last time and then at the same
time they don't want to say anything
about this ending so it makes it seem
like there's a possibility there could
be more or even a spin-off or something
like that clyde phillips says that it's
going to be satisfying and controversial
and you do have to wonder if this is
supposed to be a proper ending if they
came back to do that because people
weren't satisfied with how it ended
before then they must have had an idea
that would feel final
dexter's living in the small town under
an alias he seems to build a life for
himself and for that to be the case he
must have gone through some changes over
the decade give or take since we last
saw him in oregon that makes the setup
feel like he's on the brink of just
living out this normal life and then
things get turned upside down
they didn't give away much new
information about the supporting
characters i talked about clancy brown's
character dexter's new girlfriend and
the true crime podcaster in my last
video and it sounds like she doesn't
show up in iron lake until a few
episodes after harrison arrives it does
look like there's another killer in town
and of course that would be of interest
to the old dexter and there is a new
shot of him hitting some unnamed
character in the latest footage
it all looks pretty good and the way
that they're talking about it it sounds
promising when i heard him declare that
it'll be satisfying and controversial my
first thought was that maybe harrison
was going to take dexter out although
that might just be because i do want to
see dexter's story have an end and none
of the ways that might happen seem
particularly controversial i'm really
not sure if they could pull that off
though i mean sure there's the
connection of them both being born in
blood with harrison witnessing rita's
death and dex did abandon him with
hannah which may not have been the most
nurturing situation plus the resentments
the whole sins of the father theme but
it feels like it would take a lot of
work for them to get to where that would
feel like a fitting conclusion and i
think rather than just rambling on i'll
put out a separate predictions video in
the coming weeks to put all this stuff
together for now i'll leave you with
this from michael c hall i certainly do
hope that watching the show is a
satisfying experience for people who
watched it originally and are curious
about what happened to him i certainly
hope it does provide some definitive
answers that aren't primarily mystifying
to people
i'm looking forward to see what happens
when jim lindsey gives into his urges
and gives up the struggle with his dark
passenger let me know in the comments
what you're looking forward to and your
theories about where this thing's going
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon
you